autre géant américain de l'internet
twitter le réseau social fait face à la
justice aujourd'hui il est accusé par
plusieurs associations de lutte contre
les discriminations de manquer à ses
obligations en matière de modération de
contenus plus de précision avec katia
technique au tribunal judiciaire de
paris
quatre associations sos homophobie et
sos racisme les ong j'accuse ainsi que
l'union des étudiants juifs de france
demande que twitter assure une meilleure
modération des contenus il souhaite que
la loi française soit respectée
cette loi sur la lutte contre la haine
en ligne imposent aux réseaux sociaux
accessibles en france de communiquer
publiquement sur les moyens mis en place
pour modérer les contenus or la
médiation intervenu avec les quatre
associations et le réseau social en
octobre 2020 n'a pas permis à leurs yeux
de connaître ses moyens les avocats
présents parmi eux patrick klugman ou
alain jakubowicz ont fait valoir le bien
fondé d'un procès sur cette base ils
veulent qu'un expert soit nommé pour
vérifier ces données et connaître le
nombre des modérateurs leur nationalité
la localisation car le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que la modération est
beaucoup moins heureux opérationnel sur
twitter que sur facebook ou instagram
selon un rapport commandé par la
commission européenne en 2020
twitter ne supprime que 14,29 % des
signalements des utilisateurs non
experts le chiffre chez instagram où
facebook est de 70%
une explication peut-être la compagnie
twitter emploie environ 5000 personnes
en tout dans le monde avec un chiffre
d'affaires d'un milliard en comparaison
facebook emploie quinze mille modérateur
simplement pour cette activité
m klugman a donc dénoncé une haine en
ligne systémique par absence de moyens
l'avocat de twitter a ensuite plaidé
il estime que les données sont
communiqués et qu'en revanche les
demandes non fondées ne reçoivent pas de
réponse et qu'on ne peut rendre twitter
responsables de tels ou tels dégâts
survenus
nous sommes donc dans la tente pour
savoir si un procès va être intentée au
réseau social